foreign
it's all about this a canal that Haitian
farmers are digging to divert the
masakri river which runs along the
border with the Dominican Republic
Farmers say they're desperate
we need this water for our crops we
won't be pressured out of it by anyone
it's life or death
but the Dominican Republic is not happy
officials said the canal goes against
the treaty signed more than 90 years ago
prohibiting each country from altering
the course of the river
early Friday morning the Dominican
president took the rare step of closing
the Border by land sea and air until
there's a resolution over the canal
the Border will be closed for as long as
is necessary the Army Navy and Air Force
are ready to fulfill this order
meanwhile we are still in talks with the
Haitian government
the Haitian government released a
statement saying that it could decide on
the exploitation of its natural
resources and had complete right to
access the river
but the Border closure will hit both
countries hard especially Haiti it's by
far the poorest of the two more than
half the population is at risk of
starving according to the United Nations
and many people depend on cross-border
trade more than 25 percent of Haiti's
recorded Imports come from the Dominican
Republic
[Laughter]
for us the problem we have is that we
don't know why why are things like this
meanwhile those who are digging the
canal are defiant on Thursday they
launch an impromptu protest of their own
they say that they're already 11 canals
on the Dominican side
they don't respect us and they take us
as vandals but the river is for the two
of us 50 for them and 50 for us
we are defending our environment we are
defending our territory and the
population needs our help to build the
canal
Brick by Brick despite the Border
closure they're carrying on John Holman
Al Jazeera
wildest fires are burning
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera